dans du parti de l'ump beau jour il sort
chaque corps du républicain est
républicain
pardon je suis en retard d'une guerre si
je puis dire le mot est mal choisi mais
effectivement une réforme du nom de
votre parti vous êtes président de la
république un merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous ce matin sur lci christian jacob
on va tout de suite parlé des
municipales le conseil scientifique a
rendu un avis pas franchement tranché il
dit oui mais en ce qui concerne la
possible tenue d'un second tour fin juin
ils disent aussi difficile d'anticiper
une situation incertaine il faudra
réviser quinze jours avancent pas très
directif qu'allez vous dire ce soir au
premier ministre qui vous reçoit à
matignon sur ce calendrier des
municipales christian jacob écoutez
quand les choses semblent compliquées
pour revenir sur des basses abeba simple
c'est la loi la loi du 23 du 23 mars que
le gouvernement nous a proposé de voter
que nous avons d'ailleurs voté la loi il
dit deux choses très claire elle dit
qu'à partir du moment où des communes
ont besoin d'un deuxième tour ça
concerne à peu près cinq mille 5000
communes ce deuxième tour se devra se
tenir au plus tard au mois de juin
ensuite elle dîne deuxième chose la date
précise de ce deuxième tour devra être
fixé en conseil des ministres au plus
tard le 27 mai donc il faut rester sur
cette sur cette base et que le
gouvernement et le président de la
république donc assume les décisions
prises dans cette foi de quoi est née la
polémique
on voit à monter en ce moment elle est
née tout simplement du fait que le
président de la république et le premier
ministre ne veulent pas assumer la
décision qui est dans la loi que eux
mêmes ont fait voter au parlement alors
je sais pas si ça cache détention
d'ailleurs entre eux mais si on reste
sur la base de la loi les choses sont
relativement simples alors là le vote
que vous évoquez c'est l'état d'urgence
sanitaire qui effectivement aborde
énormément de dispositions dont celle là
mais le gouvernement a prévenu que la
décision finale serait tranchée
effectivement plus tard le 27 mai mai
si vous étiez au pouvoir vous
n'hésiteriez pas moi ce que je suis la
situation sanitaire que ce que j'ai dit
à plusieurs reprises c'est qu'à partir
du moment les conditions sanitaires le
permettent il faut aller le plus
rapidement possible parce qu'il ya un
enjeu économique est énorme
ce sont des milliers d'entreprises et
des dizaines de milliers d'emplois qui
sont en jeu avec la commande publique
voyez un secteur comme les travaux
publics dépend à peu près à 70% de la
commande publique et sur la commande
publique les communes à elle seule
représente à peu près 70 % donc on voit
tout de suite l'importance que ça en
termes de rendement poids économique
il ya un intérêt économique est évident
mais ce qui prime sur les conditions
sanitaires
je pense que la vie du quai à quai rendu
par le comité scientifique permet
effectivement dire que rien aussi de s'y
opposer il demande d'avoir un contrôle
qu'un jour avant mais c'est trop
demander au gouvernement de dire oui
pour le 28 juin
mais quinze jours avant je suis un gars
je demande au gouvernement d'appliquer
la loi qui nous ont proposé de voter
c'est simple oui d'accord mais encore
une fois le gouvernement a le droit
d'hésiter entre guillemets compte tenu
des conditions sanitaires
enfin il hésite depuis 48 heures ce
jeudi
lorsque j'ai le sentiment qui a encore
une fois une tension jeu contre une
tension des positions différentes entre
le président de la république et le
premier ministre et qui sont sur le
registre c'est pas moi qui ai décidé ce
sont les autres c'est à dire ce qu'il
veut leur père en fait ce qu'il souhaite
c'est pouvoir dire à ceux qui souhaitent
que les élections se tiennent au mois de
juin de dire voyez j'ai proposé que ce
soit au mois de juin et ceux qui
souhaitent les reporté en octobre voire
en mars prochain de dire écoutez moi je
voulais mais ceux qui n'ont pas voulu
qu'ils assument la loi la loi et nous
l'ont fait voter et donc il suffit
d'appliquer
donc vous dites qui se défaussent sur
vous il se défausse ce soir il va vous
écouter et éventuellement il pourrait
dire après c'est ce que c'est ce que
vous soupçonnez on les a organisés parce
qu'on nous l'a demandé qu'ils prennent
moi je dire rester dans le cadre de la
loi monsieur le premier ministre vous
nous a fait voter une loi mettez la en
application gouvernement a été échaudé
vous le savez mieux christian jacob il a
été accusé
maintenu ce premier tour après que tous
les partis lui avait demandé de le
tennis c'est totalement fou ça c'est
totalement faux jamais jamais bien
jamais les parties on n'a jamais
sollicité l'avis du parquet le premier
ministre nous a dit voilà ce que vous
propose le premier tour ait lieu le 15
mars
à condition que les barrières sanitaires
soient soient respectés c'est comme ça
que s'est tenue la réunion du jeudi
matin ensuite ça je vous parle de
déclaration
oui oui bien sûr bien sûr vous aviez
premier tour bien sûr bien sûr tard bien
sûr on est bien sûr bien sûr mais je
vais vous répondre avec beaucoup de
précision nous avons une réunion le
jeudi matin depuis il ya eu x l'émission
et commentaires sur le sujet jamais à
aucun moment la vie n'a été demandée aux
différents partis donnent l'occasion de
cette réunion du jeudi matin d'ailleurs
tous les groupes d'opposition en
témoigne ensuite le midi deux heures
après né à débat pour dire on va
reporter les élections à semoy jeux
d'écouté soit le premier ministre a
caché des informations dont ils avaient
connaissance le matin soit on se fiche
de nous et à ce moment là ce serait
effectivement ça pourrait être un coup
d'état c'est ce que j'ai dit à nous
était un peu fort vous le reconnaissez
oui le mot est peut-être fort mais
imaginez on vous réunit le le matin on
vous dit aucun problème les élections
vont se tenir comme ça
maintenant il faut que vont se tenir à
cette date il faut que chaque commune
respectent les distances barrières etc
et que deux heures après quand la
réunion terminée dit mais peut-être
qu'on va changer la date quand même vous
dites il n'avait pas demandé notre avis
il vous le demande ne donnez leclerc
m'exprimer clairement je pense ou
l'avoir exprime assez clairement me
semble-t-il
oui mais je n'ai exemple vous voulez pas
d'un voté au parlement et non mais
mais parce que tout simplement ce n'est
pas une loi le vote mais on vous demande
votre avis ne vais pas je viens non mais
je viens de vous donner le nom donne pas
assez de pouvoir notamment on consulte
pas suffisamment le parlement et alors
qu'on vous proposerai spa décidé vous
proposerai un débat au parlement avec un
vote éventuellement tout ça est en
question vous dirai au premier ce que
vous êtes contre manifestement non non
ne chante pas dure que
je viens de vous expliquer moi je
considère qu'il ya un enjeu économique
est déterminant c'est la raison pour
laquelle je suis favorable à ce que les
exigences se tiennent le plus rapidement
possible ensuite je veux pas je demande
simplement au premier ministre
d'appliquer la loi qui nous a fait voter
il aurait pu dire dans mais dans ce
texte on va fixer à l'issue d'un débat
parlementaire on va fixer le mes doit
fixer la date par là par la loi ça n'est
pas le cas revenons à des choses simples
les shows sap on a voté noah sur
proposition du gouvernement
nous avons nous opposition voter cette
loi ce qui n'était pas évident parce que
vous dire que le parlement se défaisait
d'un certain nombre de pouvoirs canton
votre les ordonnances
donc on reste dans dans ce cadre là moi
je suis favorable je l' ai toujours dit
à ce que les élections
ces conditions sanitaires le permet de
se tiennent le plus rapidement possible
pour des conditions économiques donc pas
être plus clair avec vous vous avez vous
même évoqué les réserves de richard
ferrand président de l'assemblée
effectivement lui il est plutôt
favorable
manifestement un report même jusqu'en
mars 2021 ce qui dit une chose assez
simple comment faire campagne
pas de meeting pas de tractage pas ne
porte à porte vous qui aimez tant que ce
sens jacobs les campagnes en disciple de
jacques chirac
vous qui aimez bien les contacts est ce
que ce ne serait pas une mascarade comme
l'avait dit agnès buzyn franchement
coûté les dizaines de milliers d'emplois
qui sont en cause les les milliers
d'entreprises qui risquent de faire
faillite demain parce que la commande
publique ne sera pas passé ce qu'il faut
bien comprendre c'est qu'on ne parle pas
que en europe qui représente à peu près
50% et des français que des comme des
5000 communes en question mais de toutes
les intercommunalités qui ont la
compétence économique
ça veut dire que jamais de projets
ne seront ne seront votées et mises en
débat est donc la loi est votée elle
éclaire les sans ambiguïté que le
premier ministre et le président la
république applique la loi qu'ils ont
fait voter au parlement
ça me semble pas oui son ordinaire
composition donc entre risques
sanitaires et intérêts économiques cet
arbitrage qui se posent sur la question
mais quand on est dans l'hexagone et
vous savez j'ai choisi ce lot et les
intérêts économiques j'ai été maire
pendant 16 ans gouverner c'est choisir
c'est décidé et est ce que vous
envisagez que quinze jours avant on dit
stop
si une deuxième vague écoutez moi je
suis capable et on pourra dire c'est un
pee wee mai mais est ce que vous êtes
capable de me dire que non il n'y aura
jamais aucune reprise de la pandémie
est ce que vous pouvez me dire ça ou est
ce que vous pouvez me dire exactement le
contraire oui avec certitude y en aura
je n'en sais rien donc je pense qu'il ya
des conditions aujourd'hui qui
permettent de pouvoir tenir ce ce
deuxième tour maintenant si premier
ministre décide autrement
vos critiques rêve ou le non non non
j'ai toujours dit il si leurs
partenaires
en fait j'ai toujours dit que sur ce
sujet moi je faisais confiance en
fonction des informations qu'il avait
moins les informations qui la laisse à
penser qu'on peut organiser ce ce
deuxième tour en juin mais c'est sa
décision qu'ils apprennent bien dire
s'ils ont peur de gouvernants qu'ils
disent aussi à un moment présent qu'il
prenne sa décision à la peine de vous
consulter
sinon ce serait une façon qu'ont les
responsabilités mais non je ne voulais
pas donc je vais lui dire ce soir c'est
toute cette position mais en tout cas
pas de vote au parlement d'un vote au
parlement
lortie si papa sow ne relève pas de
décision ne feriez pas au vote
je pense que ça ça ne relève pas d'une
décision du parlement que le premier
temps c'est quand même trop facile de
dire en fonction du sujet si nous
arrange ou pas on renvoie là en quelque
sorte la patate chaude coûté
gouvernement dit c'est trop facile de
vouloir absolument peser sur les
décisions de réclamer d'être consultés
et puis ensuite de dire on veut pas on
veut pas s'exprimer je veux clairement
devant je veux simplement qu'on applique
la loi de ces simples à appliquer la loi
que le gouvernement nous a fait voter
avant le 27 mai le rythme du
déconfinement christian jacob vous aviez
dit ya quelques jours une bonne
quinzaine de jours sur lci que vous
étiez favorable à l'époque à une
réouverture des restaurants le 11 mais
ça n'a pas été décidée ça devrait l'être
le 2 juin pour les zones vertes
satisfaisant moi je pense qu'il faut
relancer l'économie rapidement et
réouvrir partout on le peut démarrer et
reste en zone rouge quand même non mais
sur les sur les zones vertes en revanche
je pense qu'on peut adapter le critère
des des quatre mètres carrés voyez si
vous allez si moi je vais bon mes
enfants sont maintenant dans mes mais
lorsqu'il est encore à la maison si je
vais dîner dans un restaurant avec ma
femme et mes et mes enfants on vit tous
les quatre dans la même maison donc on
n'a pas besoin de quatre mètres carrés
chacun au restaurant donc on peut aussi
adapter les règles de distance de façon
à pouvoir redémarrer l'économie demandé
aux familles leur livret de famille
mais simplement vous vous décidez de
savoir avec qui vous allez dîner voilà
d'accord on vous oblige pas encore à
dîner à quelqu'un donc c'est jouable
dans les zones vertes les zones rouges
non non les les zones on joue gros ce
moment je pense qu'il faut aussi dans
votre main d'or en vain par exemple eh
bien elle sera en corse et en ile de
france on est malheureusement toujours
en zone rouge est sorti rapidement
situation économique qui s'annonce
gravissime avec un chômage de masse
catastrophique le canard enchaîné révèle
ce matin que l'entreprise renault qui
vient de bénéficier d'un prêt de 5
milliards d'euros de l'état le canard
enchaîné croit savoir que l'entreprise
envisage la fermeture de quatre sites
dont l'emblématique flins alors qu'il
pourrait changer en tout cas de
production comment vous réagissez si
renault affirme que c'est la seule
solution pour ne pas couler il faut
laisser faire
lorsqu'il faut regarder les choses de
près notamment le l'état un rôle
déterminant dans d'un renault c'est ce
qui compte bien et finalement c'est de
maintenir l'entreprise
bon moi je suis surpris je découvre les
chiffres comme comme vous de 4,6 de
cette importance remis en cause ça me
paraît vraiment énorme
donc il faut regarder quelles sont les
solutions milliards d'économies distille
pour poupée d'où l'intérêt d'organiser
le plan de relance très rapidement c'est
la raison d'ailleurs pour laquelle non
républicain nous avons milité pour que
le plan de relance interviennent avant
l'été et qu'on n'attende pas l'automne
pour le plan de relance il ya besoin
d'un accompagnement de l'économie le
plus rapidement s'ils sont tard le plan
de relance en septembre annoncée par
bruno le maire moi je compte sur
l'instant et l'orangé pas rejoint dans
la gestion de la crise il faudrait quoi
un plan de relance en juillet moi je
pense qu'il faut le faire oui avant
l'été et dont 11 septembre juillet
septembre
mais ce n'est pas pareil ce n'est pas la
même chose parce que vous avez le temps
du parlement vous connaissez qui va
effectivement prendre du temps sur une
section est extraordinaire en septembre
je pense que si on peut le faire avant
l'été et on peut le faire avant l'été
sur le c'est une décision politique
c'est à mon avis bien mieux ça permet
aux entreprises s'adaptent et de savoir
où ils vont faire en économie la pire
des choses c'est l'instabilité
c'est de ne pas savoir où va donc plus
vite les entreprises sauront de quelle
manière ils sont accompagnés mieux ce
sera d'où la nécessité d'avoir ce plan
de relance qui interviennent rapidement
la question qui va être posée arnaud vie
pourra d'ailleurs être bien j'ai à
l'occasion de la loi de finances à
l'automne s'est pas non plus résister en
juillet et ensuite voter on peut le
présenter et lors des sessions de
dynamique de soutien psychologique
presse louise mais moi je pense mais en
ce qui concerne renault 5 milliards de
prêts garantis par l'état y avait pas de
contrepartie très clair sur l'emploi est
ce que vous le regrettez ou est-ce que
vous laisser aux entreprises ne soit le
choix de disposer de cette manne
publique comme il l'entend comme elle
l'entend les grilles est que ce soit
plus directif à chaque fois que l'état
vient au secours d'une entreprise
stratégique écouter ceux qui connaissent
le mieux l'entreprise ces soupçons dans
l'entreprise en règle en règle générale
et donc moi je pense que ça doit être
fait en étroite relation avec avec les
entreprises pour faire en sorte qu'elle
puisse continuer parfois il ya besoin on
voit bien d'ailleurs la mesure de
chômage partiel qui était une bonne
mesure d'ailleurs que nous avons
nous avons voté un a permis de redonner
de l'oxygène ou d'éviter que les
entreprises en perte de trop de
l'oxygène il faut aussi sortir de ce ce
chômage partiel donc ça peut être un
certain moment une solution mais bien
évidemment que l'objectif c'est non
seulement de maintenir le maximum
d'emplois mais que la machine ciel le
patron du medef geoffroy roux de bézieux
a dit dimanche c'est trop tôt début juin
oui faut il faut l'adapter en fonction
des circonstances il accorde à zarqa où
un quasiment oui on a des secteurs on
sait qu'il aura besoin d'accompagner
plus longtemps voyez par exemple sur le
tourisme on voit bien qu après ce qui
s'est passé l'été la saison qui va quand
même être catastrophique
les difficultés pour les sites les sites
d'automne dont il y aura besoin sans
doute de plus longs dans d'autres
secteurs où l'activité de production
peut redémarrer plus rapidement eh bien
il faudra jouer sur 7 sur 7 sous peuple
d'adaptation à chaque fois au plus près
possible de l'entreprise et du bon de
commande
à propos de prendre plan de relance
bravo emmanuel macron cas convaincu
angela merkel de mutualiser 500
milliards d'euros qui vont profiter aux
pays les plus touchés par la crise
c'est le plan d'ailleurs sur lequel la
commission européenne travaille depuis
depuis plusieurs semaines prévoit que je
m'en tiens tournant pour la no men
attendons d'abord qu'il soit 10 soit
votée il va être présentée par la
commission européenne ce n'est pas
quelque chose qui sort du chapeau du
sommet hier c'est un travail qui est
fait déjà depuis plusieurs semaines par
là par la commission européenne pour
préparer ce plan de relance je pense que
c'est une bonne chose qu'il y ait un
plan de relance européen qu'ils soient
lancées tout simplement parce qu'on va
voir on aura des taux aujourd'hui la
marque de l'union européenne est
rassurante pour les prêteurs et donc on
aura des taux plus bas donc c'est
forcément intéressant pour relancer la
machine
ensuite va se poser une autre question
comment on garantit ce prêt qui le
garantis ce sont les états en fonction
d'eux
deux des montants qu'ils utiliseront sur
quels critères de mutualisation nous
attendons de voir de voir tout cela
pourrit d'allemands est ce que vous
dites que pour l'europe
c'est une victoire et pour le couple
franco allemand
c'est une bonne chose que l'europe
puisse avoir ce plan de 500 milliards
il est positif de l'europe
oui hélas ce mécanisme alors on fait
rien on continue dans lequel l'allemagne
accepte de financer des pays dont ils
estimaient qu'ils étaient des cigales
budgétaire c'est nouveau oui alors
voyons les conditions dans lesquelles
tout ça va se faire c'est moi je reste
prudent entre une annonce conférence de
presse hier
attendons le 27 mai le 27 mai il va être
présentée par la commission
on va voir la réaction des états
regarder quel système de garantie de
quelle façon il va être utilisé mais
diable est dans les détails dans les
mécanismes vous mais ne cadrait pas
besoin de rêve de triompher
on a eu l'idée d'un fonds européen est
une bonne chose françois baroin a été
très prudent pendant la crise
quand des ténors de l air se
démultipliait quand il ya une guerre on
ne joue pas les planqués c'est ce qu'ont
pu penser certains de vos élus allaient
à son sujet vous comprenez cette
réaction
absolument pas pour le coup il était au
feu et aux feux dans sa commune moi qui
suis voisin de la ville de troyes dans
ses responsabilités de maire il l'a été
avec l'association des maires de france
également et qui ont été qui ont comblé
d'ailleurs dans bien des cas les
défaillances de l'état qui ont été qui
ont été nombreuses heureusement on a eu
les collectivités d'ailleurs pas que les
villes et quelle que soit leur étiquette
politique
les maires ont été à la fois en
proximité et en réactivité
comme d'ailleurs les présidents des
exécutifs départementaux et régionaux
françois baroin d'accusation légitime
sur son sens ce serait un non sens
regardez ce qu'il a fait dans sa ville
de troyes et la racaille qui l'a fait m
le groupe lrn a perdu la majorité
absolue après plusieurs de ses élus
on choisi de déserter vous qui avez été
longtemps patron du groupe ump cette
fois nous semblait qu est ce que vous
pensez de ces élus qui sont à lire sur
une étiquette et qui change de cheval en
cours de partie
forcément pas beaucoup de pas beaucoup
de bien mais au-delà de cela moi je
trouve ça complètement catastrophique et
j'appelle la majorité pour les manuels
mais pour l'assemblée nationale
j'appelle le président de l'assemblée
nationale
à regarder les choses en face et un
délitement du parlement la réalité c'est
ça quand le premier ministre à
intervenir
neuf groupes parlementaires ça ressemble
à quoi j'avais fait une composition ce
n'est pas nouveau ça fait bientôt dix
ans que je les fais deux
de dire qu'un groupe parlementaire
devait représenter au moins 10% des
députés de l'assemblée nationale c'est à
dire que ce soit 50 58 manque ça fait du
sens au parlement tant que tel mais bien
entendu mais s'adressant plus à rien sur
des gens qui auraient interviennent au
nom de 15 personnes qu'est-ce qui auront
passé c'est un coup dur aussi pour la
majorité ou en fait avec le modem et
agir ils auront toujours des majorités
kiener non bien sûr bat rc c'est une
explosion si internet est cette
expression façon paul ii du du groupe
parlementaire de la majorité
mais ceci est en deçà ne doit pas nous
réjouir parce que c'est un
affaiblissement du parlement vous allez
bien oui je le dire touché par un des
premiers élus républicains être touchés
donc vous en êtes remis trois ce moulin
et le reste et riom enfin rôle à la
période où c'était difficile a été plus
court que ça j'ai eu un claro pichot pas
non parce qu'ils étaient soignés par ces
machines là aussi un raisonnement simple
quand je suis malade je vais voir mon
médecin et je suis ces indications à ses
prescriptions mère que j'ai fait ça a
plutôt bien marché
voilà bon rétablissement définitif merci
beaucoup question jacob d'avoir été avec
nous ce matin sur le plateau de lci au à
la elizabeth vertige et de merci merci
beaucoup à 8h51